and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review of the
Great and Powerful you've ever seen in
my life these new pls like spoilers dear
sis guy cold eyes I wonder who named him
after a prison show he dreams about
being the world's greatest magician like
David Bowie with tell it well it turns
out a bunch of the people don't like him
because he can't make a little girl walk
geez tough crowd you know folks it's the
difference between a magician and Jesus
and then he suddenly gets released away
through a giant tornado I was in a
tornado once I was living in a trench
kid but that the painting came along put
it all these little sensors and it threw
me you are mean Bill Paxton so why is he
sent to us is that kind of like Disney
of the prison going to Disney the theme
park and she comes across Meg from that
70 show we know I remember the name of
it it was a pretty bunch and she's like
you are the wizard with the province he
says we'll save us all um okay and what
prophecy is this the purpose even down
to notebook and we can't remember who
said it well are you sure that's a
prophecy we're following you
okay made my skin turned green in my
nose and she can't really make if I'm
wrong that's bizarre be specific I'm in
love with you now it's good thing you're
hot because you're really weird so many
takes into the Emerald City to meet her
sister and oz is like you must be her
sister I can tell by the fact you're
older taller I look nothing like your an
British brother but the sister is like
you must defeat the evil witch so you
can bring all the back to Oz but wait a
minute
you're a witch why don't you go stab her
because I have an incredible amount of
power and you don't like if it mixes so
they also come across a monkey played by
the doctor from Scrubs and the monkey is
like I II will show you around and left
over photoshop backgrounds from Alice in
Wonderland wait what's that tell me to
China
Chinatown it's a leftover pun from
wreck-it Ralph but we come across this
little girl made of China and they're
like do you have a name they don't try
to kill nice I'm just gonna call you
Little China girl's rival to the movie
stop in Little China girl away
don't come across the Wicked Witch which
it turns out it's actually a good witch
and dies it's like you're a good witch
rate that you are bad witch which is a
good winter bad winter the hastily
written which that will eventually
become a bad witch oh no I better not do
anything that could easily be taken the
wrong way if she's watching the sisters
like eat this Apple and you will become
evil in my minion why don't you just
give that to everybody in the kingdom
make them all your slaves never crash
your mind eat this I met you guys start
working on that oh I also got remember
to work in the ruby slippers in case I
forget to write it in don't let me
forget that though the lunar winters are
not evil witches and the bad witch is a
good witch but oz is like me we use my
tailor tricks to defeat their army
oh by tricking you all into thinking I'm
dead totally jeopardizing the plan that
I could have just told you from the
beginning I was going to do why would
you do this party's ending that
everybody will see coming
so Flora's parlor tricks for evil
witches are scared away as this the king
of the land Bruce Campbell has a five
second cameo even though he's mentioned
in the opening credits and we can all
remember that rachel weisz has a career
three so how does the Great and Powerful
was really great and powerful but like I
said before it was missing for me
sleepers I wanted puppies slippers no
not in the movie I mean they real ly
although I guess if I said there's no
place like Comey would just take me back
to my pop-tart box but I could sell them
I just have to find someone that makes
really crazy eccentric media purchases
yeah wonder what maker is up to this is
history bum sing really surprised you
got ruby slippers come on take my shirts
the slipper
you